it's really hard to imagine your life
one way and just think it's set and then
when that goes away kind of feeling like
Who am I in some of the relationships
that I've had in the past
I only know myself with another person
and that's not a good place to be in
because when that person is gone then
you're left with I don't even know who I
am I'm Hannah Brown and today I'm unfit
third but I'm usually always unfiltered
I've always been long-winded I don't
know if I can tell myself and I mean I
don't know if I can describe myself in
just a few words I think I am
complicated definitely been a Mama's
girl forever and so the first time I
recognized beauty was I think just
watching my mom get ready and I think my
mom is so beautiful she has the
prettiest blue eyes and was really
excited whenever I had force idols when
I was younger to be able to put on some
makeup and feel confident
I guess makeup for me when I was younger
was correlated to like performing and
being onstage sometimes I've let it
dissipate in my life but obviously now I
get to perform and be myself for
everybody
my mom would always get so mad at me if
I didn't have color on my lips and I
used to think it was so annoying but
mascara and lip gloss you got to have it
or just own the troll that you are
trolling I have a different definition
of what trolling is now I understand
like internet trolls like the mean
people that just like Facebook moms I
hate me like yard trolls but when I say
I'm a troll or I'm trolling it's when I
look not my best when my hair hasn't
been washed in a few days or I just
washed it but let it air-dry and in my
face is all just freaked up that's me
basically every day
trolling they see me rollin they hatin
I'm not a songwriter and I'm done with
songwriters sweet
[Music]
my mom says I was a really good baby
actually that she could keep me in the
stroller and she could go shopping and I
was very content
I loved dressing up I loved putting on
shows I loved watching Oprah and Ellen I
would use my hairbrush and be a host as
well I've always struggled with this I
think I love to perform and I like I
like showcasing like oh look what I did
and Here I am but then I also can might
retract and be very shy and
uncomfortable I'm actually very
introverted I grew up in Tuscaloosa
Alabama I lived in the same house my
entire life I was hard on myself at a
young age and I think maybe I was
because my mom was gorgeous I watched
her sometimes be critical of herself and
she I thought she was my life-size
Barbie and I think then from there I
started seeing other women kind of pick
it themselves so then I started looking
at myself I can't remember being like
five years old and looking in my
American girl magazines with the dolls
with the girls and my limited to that
was during my time and thinking I didn't
look like them like I was a little
chubbier I just was so self-conscious as
a little girl because insecurities have
carried on as I got older I did pageants
so I got pretty good at putting these on
I saw a pamphlet at my school in the
counselor's office for Miss Alabama is
outstanding teen and I had always
watched the Miss USA the Miss America
pageant's and would put on my mom's
heels and walk around but I'd never done
a pageant and I brought the paper at
home and was like mom look at this like
it's it's about scholarship and you can
get money for your school and have a
and I was all about it but my mom still
wasn't so sure
but then my aunt actually had me for a
weekend and I won the pageant she got me
ready and I won and so it kind of just
started from there and I saw pageants as
a way to be a role model I think that
was always very important to me to live
my life by a certain way that I was
proud of I think being in pageantry was
very beneficial for me and did shape and
mold me in a lot of positive ways but I
lost myself a lot in it you know you're
putting yourself out there to be judged
by three random people four random
people who don't know your heart who
could be having an off date they might
just not like blonds and it's very hard
not to start questioning what's wrong
with you and started looking to my left
to my right and listening to what people
were saying that I should do your hair
should be blonder Oh like you look great
but maybe if you like lost five pounds
really quick you'd look better a lot of
those comments really started to make me
question who I was but I took a break I
got really honest with myself about oh
wait I'm not happy and nobody's really
asked me if I was happy they just saw
how to smile on my face
tackling the conversations of mental
help and using that as my platform to be
a voice of hey it's okay to not be okay
I was really powerful for me and I think
that's when it all changed and I did
become Miss Alabama USA because I was so
candid about where my life had gone
where I'd been where I am now and the
judges that allowed me to start this
journey I feel like it started there
it's so wild how all this started for me
and how I actually became a contestant
on The Bachelor I feel like my friends
always joked with me about like oh my
god you need to like have your own
reality TV show because she was just
crazy but not crazy crazy like fun crazy
fun I got randomly nominated for The
Bachelor kind of just went through it
very blindly but this is hilarious sure
why not and uh well it wasn't a joke and
I ended up just like taking a leap of
faith I really was interested in Colton
I thought like he had his own platform
and was a handsome guy and like had a
lot going for him and I'm like I can see
myself with somebody like that so if
it's Colton I will go on the show and
then it ended up being him cells like
okay I guess we're gonna do this thing
Thanks
deals of Colton's The Bachelor and that
use aversion is super appealing to me
Alabama Hannah is ready free so
interesting now that I have seen a lot
more of the world and met so many
different people like I realize how how
young I am but at the time of going on
The Bachelor being the Bachelorette I
didn't think of it as strange thinking
and talking about marriage like all my
friends are married back home have
babies I had been in two serious
relationships before where I really
thought I'd be married by now
now I get it but not everybody gets
married as an infant but I still do
believe that I am if it was with the
right person I'd be ready for that at
this time of my life
like I still want that there's still a
desire of my heart I don't know but I'm
okay with being single - I still want a
guy a man to do life with like that
would be so fun to share that was
somebody I have finally gotten to a
point where I'm okay being the one I
keep doing my own thing and becoming my
best self I'm hoping wishing praying
that the God that I'm supposed to be
with is doing the same thing right now
and we'll just be better for each other
whenever that day happens and Wow it's
not magic it's hard work I think early
show but you know what I mean
and stuff is really on there this is not
the same I make up a hat on on The
Bachelor this season sure like there is
still I get something when I saw you
that day afar I think very differently
now about things because I have had so
many oh my gosh moments for everybody to
watch so I was like you know what for a
mascara stain face you don't look that
bad in and they got some good lighting
right now oh my it looks very dramatic
is this not thousand is so like I have
had sex
yeah
you know Jesus still loves me
I remember being like how am I the sex
girl I like didn't think I was gonna
have sex before I was married like I was
not sexually active I mean I didn't have
my first kiss till I was 17
like I really put value in my
relationships and my the people that I'm
physical with and thought it would be my
husband and when I lost my virginity I
thought it was going to be of course I
thought that was gonna be the guy that I
was going to marry when that
relationship didn't work I mean I just
was like great I'm ruined
which is so sad it's been very hard and
interesting to see what how people view
me I had never been called a [ __ ] before
because hello I wasn't and so for the
first time for people to know who I am
to then now be calling me a [ __ ] and
permiss us was very hard but I do think
that's a big part of a relationship and
I'm totally I'm for whatever makes you
feel comfortable
and I just had to really own up to that
it's not that I'm not worthy now I think
it was really powerful for other girls
too
almost like being able to have that
moment through me even though I didn't
even want to have it you know like have
to deal with the repercussions that I
kind of that I got after being honest
about my sex life and standing up for my
sending up for myself to a man that
deemed me unworthy because I had felt
that way before and I mean no woman
should feel like her past sexual history
makes them not worthy of love
I keep trying to get it all off date
marry disappear with my final three guys
date Tyler marry Peter disappear what's
you say okay let's make a toast to let's
make it taste even put some words
together so put a bunch of words that
sound good
that are real they're real the biggest
thing that I've discovered about myself
now being in the spotlight is I am so
much stronger than I thought I was I was
at first being on The Bachelor and
seeing like critical comments and I saw
that would crush me
but now hundreds thousands of people
have something negative say about me and
I have learned that if I'm gonna
continue to do what I'm supposed to do
and move forward that I cannot let that
faze me and sometimes it still hurts but
I really am proud of myself
and that's cool to be able to say still
struggle still not perfect
far from it but proud of proud of this
girl
I have acne
[Music]
I've always not always struggled I
started getting adult acne I like 23 I
have never felt more like I had a mask
on nobody could really see me because of
my skin not being a true reflection of
Who I am and that was that was really
hard and I never struggled with it
before been at 23 being like oh this is
what it feels like
it's really crippling and now my face is
breaking out again but I just refused to
cover up like Who I am and and what I'm
going through
also I don't try to hide it because I
think where a lot of us are all on the
same boat with that and the ideals of
perfection and being be you too or what
beauty is is not really realistic and I
think what's inside and how you feel
about yourself and that confidence and
vulnerability is really what makes
somebody beautiful and alluring and
endearing so yeah
ABB's it's and it's okay I still think
that I have a lot to give